to china now which has revealed a plan
to strengthen its control over yet more
industries a document by china's state
council says it wants to expand
regulation further framing its approach
as consumer protection it follows a
series of crackdowns which have wiped
billions of dollars in private
investment from chinese firms as foreign
investors panic over increased
intervention by the state the country
has recently targeted tech giants like
didi and ant group after they went
public on foreign exchanges
then china announced a massive reform of
the education sector banning foreign
investors and forcing firms to convert
to non-profit status
investors feel the new plan by china is
far from benign judging by those recent
interventions the hansen tech index
which tracks stock prices of chinese
tech firms has fallen 40 percent since
february and that's over half a trillion
dollars of investment evaporated from
chinese tech
well for more on all of that i'm joined
now by fraser howie in singapore he's
been working in china's capital market
since 1992 and he's the co-author of red
capitalism the fragile foundations of
china's extraordinary rise so good to
have you uh with us fraser uh i mean
who's getting targeted this time we've
had tech we've had the education who is
targeted this time
well basically the signal is that
everybody's targeted everyone has a
target on their back i don't think that
any industry that can see it truly safe
and certainly not if you're a private
sector industry
and what about i mean 40
loss in the stock value of of chinese
tech companies since february is that in
beijing's interest do they want those
chinese grown tech companies to to bleed
out
uh well of course really no it's not in
that interest because as you say foreign
investors are panicking but also chinese
domestic investors are panicking
remember these are chinese businesses
there may be a degree of foreign funding
in them and foreigners may have given
either some seed capital or be trading
them in stock markets but these are
chinese entrepreneurs who have built
very large successful businesses in
legal sectors this is not sectors which
were deemed illegal and they got around
regulation now beijing coming over the
top and bringing more regulation
sounds good and then of course all
markets where they be in europe the
states germany or china needs regulation
but china is coming at this with a very
ideological bench
so what what is the ideology behind it
what is beijing after
well first of all it's control that the
party does not want private sector
growing large basically effectively
becoming a separate power base from the
party so there's ideological control
from a political standpoint there's also
this idea that xi jinping the leader of
china has this idea of creating a new
china and the new chinese man and woman
and that they won't waste their time
playing computer games they won't go
extend their children to crammer school
instead they'll dutifully study his
speeches and his writings um and that's
very worrying because the government
thinks it's got all the answers and
sadly economic history teaches us that
governments most certainly do not all
right right how we there in singapore
thank you so much for your time
you